what i'm going to attempt to do in the
next few videos is really just give an
overview of everything that's happened
to earth since it came into existence
and we're going to start really at the
formation of earth or the formation of
our solar system or the formation of the
sun and our best sense of what actually
happened is that there was a supernova
in our vicinity of the galaxy and this
right here is a picture of a supernova
remnant actually the remnant for
kepler's supernova the supernova in this
picture actually happened 400 years ago
in 1604 so right at the center a very a
star essentially exploded and for a few
weeks was the brightest object in the
night sky and it was observed by kepler
and other people in 1604 and this is
what it looks like now so this is what
we see is kind of the shock wave that's
been traveling out for the past 400
years and so now it must be many light
years across it wasn't obviously matter
wasn't traveling at the speed of light
but it must be must have been traveling
pretty pretty fast at least relativistic
speeds where a reasonable fraction of
the speed of light so this has traveled
a good bit out now but what you could
imagine is is when you have this shock
wave traveling out from a supernova
let's say you had a
let's say you had a cloud of molecules a
cloud of gas
that before the shock wave came by it
just wasn't dense enough it wasn't dense
enough for gravity takeover and for it
to accrete essentially into a solar
system but when the shock wave passes by
it compresses
it compresses
all of this gas and all of this material
and all of these molecules so it now
does have that critical density to form
to accrete into a star and a solar
system so we think that's what's
happening the reason why we
we feel pretty strong
pretty strongly that it must have been
caused by a supernova
is that the only way that the really
heavy elements can form or the only way
that we know that they can form is in
kind of the heat of a supernova and our
uranium the uranium that
seems to be in our solar system on earth
seems to have formed roughly at the time
of the formation of earth at about four
and a half billion years ago and we'll
talk in a little bit more depth in
future videos on exactly how people
figure that out but since the uranium
seems about the same age as our solar
system it must have been formed at
around the same time and it so it must
have been formed by a supernova and it
must be coming from a supernova so a
supernova shockwave must have passed
through our part of the universe and
that's a good reason for gas to get
compressed and begin to accrete so you
fast forward a few million years ago
that gas would have created into
something like this it would have
reached the critical temperature
critical density and pressure at the
center for ignition to occur for fusion
to start to happen for hydrogen to start
fusing into helium and this right here
is our
this right here is our early
sun around the sun you have all of the
gases and particles and molecules that
had enough angular velocity to not fall
into the sun to go into orbit around the
sun they were actually supported by a
little bit of pressure too because you
can kind of view this as kind of a big
cloud of gas so they're always bumping
into each other but for the most part it
was their angular velocity and over the
next tens of millions of years they'll
slowly bump into each other and clump
into each other even small particles
have gravity and they're going to slowly
get become
rocks and asteroids and eventually what
we would call planetesimals which are
really kind of view them as as seeds of
planets or or early planets and then
those those would have a reasonable
amount of gravity and and other things
would be attracted to them and slowly
clump up to them but this wasn't like a
simple process you know you could
imagine you might have one planetesimal
form and maybe there's another
planetesimal form and instead of having
a nice gentle those two guys are
creeding into each other they might have
huge relative velocities and ram into
each other and then just you know
shatter so this wasn't just a nice a
gentle process of constant accretion it
would actually have been a very violent
process actually happened early in
earth's history and we actually think
this is why the moon forms so at some
point you fast forward a little bit from
from this earth would have formed or i
should say the the the mass that
eventually becomes our modern earth
would have been forming
let me draw it over here
so let's say that that is
our modern earth and what we think
happened is that another proto planet or
another it was actually a planet because
it was roughly the size of mars
ran into
our what what is eventually going to
become our earth and this is actually a
picture of it this is an artist's
depiction of that collision where this
this planet right here is the size of
mars and it ran into what eventually
would become earth and this we call thea
this is
thea
and what we believe happened and if you
look up if you go onto the internet
you'll see some simulations that talk
about this is that we think it was a
glancing blow that it wasn't a direct
hit that would have just kind of
shattered each of them and turned them
into one big
molten ball we think it was a glancing
blow something like this so if this was
this was essentially earth obviously
earth got changed dramatically once thea
ran into it
but thea is right over here and we think
it was a glancing blow where it came and
it hit earth
it hit her at kind of an angle and then
it
obviously the combined the energies from
that interaction would have made both of
them molten and frankly they probably
already were molten because you had a
bunch of smaller collisions and
accretion events and little things
hitting the surface of probably both of
them
during this entire period but the the
this would have had a glancing blow on
earth and essentially splashed a bunch
of molten material out into orbit so it
would have just come in had a glancing
blow on earth and then splashed a bunch
of molten material some of it would have
been captured by earth
so this is the before and then the after
the after you could imagine
earth is kind of this molten super hot
ball
super hot ball and some of it just gets
splashed into orbit
splashed into orbit from the collision
and let me just see if i can draw thea
here so thea is
thea has collided and it is you know and
it it's it's also molten now because
huge energies and it splashes some of it
into orbit and if we fast forward a
little bit the stuff that got splashed
into orbit
this stuff that got splashed into orbit
it's going in that direction that
becomes our moon
and then the rest of this material
eventually kind of condenses back into a
spherical shape and is what is we now
what we now call
our earth so that's how we actually
think right now that the moon actually
formed and even after this happened the
earth still had a lot more i guess
violence to experience so just to just
to get a sense of where we are in the
history of earth
we're going to refer to this
time clock a lot over the next few
videos this time clock starts right here
at the formation of our solar system 4.6
billion years ago probably coinciding
with some type of supernova
and as we go clockwise
on this diagram we're moving forward in
time and we're going to go all the way
forward to the present period and just
so you understand some of the
terminology ga means billions of years
ago g for giga m a means millions of
years ago m for mega so where we are
right now we the moon has formed we're
in what we call the hadian period or
actually i shouldn't say period it's the
hadeen eon of earth period is actually
another time period so let me let me
make this very clear it's the hadiyan
we are in the hadiyan
hadian eon and an eon is kind of the
largest period of time that we talk
about especially relative to earth and
it's roughly 500 million to a billion
years is an eon and what makes the
hadian eon distinctive well from from a
geological point of view what makes it
distinctive is it's really we don't have
any rocks from the hadian period we
don't have any kind of macroscopic scale
rocks from the hadian period and that's
because at that time we believe the
earth was just this molten ball of kind
of magma and lava and it had and it was
molten because it was the product of all
of these accretion events and all of
this all of these collisions and all
this kinetic energy turning into heat so
if you were to look
at the surface of the earth if you were
to be on the surface of the earth during
the hadian eon which you probably
wouldn't want to be because you might
get hit by a falling meteorite or
probably burned by some magma whatever
it would look like this and you wouldn't
be able to breathe anyway
this is what the surface of the earth
would look like it would look like a big
magma pool and that's why we don't have
any rocks from there because the rocks
were just constantly being constantly
being recycled being dissolved and and
and churned inside of this this giant
molten ball and frankly the earth still
is a giant molten ball it's just we live
on the the super thin cooled crust of
that molten ball if you go right below
that crust and we'll talk a little bit
more about that in future videos you
will get magma and if you go dig deeper
you'll have liquid irons i mean it still
is a molten ball and this whole period
is just a violent not only was earth
itself volcanic molten ball it it began
to harden as you get to the late hadean
eon but we also had stuff falling from
the sky and constantly constantly
colliding with earth and really just
continuing to add to the heat of this
molten ball anyway i'll leave you there
and as you can imagine at this point
there was no as far as we can tell
there's no life on earth some people
believe that maybe some life could have
formed in the late hadean eon but for
the most part this is completely
inhospitable for any life forming so
i'll leave you there and we're gonna
where we take up the next video we'll
talk a little bit about the archaean eon